[Music]
she ever go back and look at season 1
footage or episodes yeah we know for
yourselves
I mean anyone on our shows as they jump
off the show or like go back and look at
footage like lies
it's like watch it's like looking at
your personal diary but in your book or
something yeah it's fun to do sir you're
too sweet
yes you are turning mute you
are disgusting get them out of here
are you embarrassed what's your reaction
when you watch the old stuff yeah what
do you consider your most embarrassing
moment I only get to choose one yeah
yeah they pick number one most
embarrassing I really like flashback are
you twins she chose my color dress every
single person at sur knows that the gray
/ blue dress is my color dress you just
don't go there I guess give her time she
still being a baby
whatever when I got really drunk at
Peter's okay yeah and it's yelling at
she and I'm yelling at Tom and like I
don't even remember that so it isn't
fair to see that over and over again our
introduction to tequila Katie yeah a
name and stigma I've been trying to shed
for sometimes you know you're out of
line
you're on the slippery slope
yeah
Blin
I thought no one even remembers except
for me was in Lake Arrowhead season two
when when we were all at the bar and I
was so drunk that I don't even know what
I was saying yeah but I'm like known as
this part like what like no you're like
[Music]
the gassy steampunk glasses I wish
that's what she was talking about no
guys so that was where I said I was
wearing you don't want them yet
thanks ma'am it was just a bunch of
gibberish always the drunken moment but
I was like hell-bent on what I was
saying was absolutely correct I don't
have to jump on there like drunken hand
where I guess it was last year when I
had that conversation station with Jax
at the finale thought it was hard you
were my last like really healthy
relationship did you use the word
healthy I'm actually like I can't
actually even believe in being like
really I'm gonna be open with you and
vulnerable with you right there's
something to be said about history with
people I've learned a lot from that
relationship I hope so
but like you treated the whole time so
the whole time no no I am so hammered I
could not put a sentence together
[Music]
you